I've loved friends since I first heard
him and then later in life I got to know
him and he has he helped me through like
so many moments where I needed somebody
to guide me through and he was just a
genius
just a true genius he was just that guy
that they'll never be anybody else like
him and it's so it's such a loss that
were that he's gone now because he could
have been one of those people that we
see every year and we get excited
because it's Prince you know what I mean
and I'll never get over it
I didn't think I was going to be able to
do the show tonight and I had to get up
to the beginning of the show and be in
and excited like yeah I Paris moment but
I tried but I was before that not in
such a good I was not in such a good
place before that you could just feel
the emotion in the room and I think
everyone was so rooting for you to be
able to you know continue with the
performance it did feel very emotional
thank you well I thought that one sweet
day was an appropriate tribute for him
and I felt like I was like stumbling
over my words and because it wasn't
rehearsed but I really thought that it
was one of the best one sweet days that
we've done and I think that um there's
not really a more appropriate song right
now in my repertoire that I have that I
could sync them prints one thing about
him that was kind of cool and and funny
and made me laugh was that he didn't
like when people did his songs he didn't
like cover songs he liked yeah he liked
other people to do their song so I was
like I'm not mad at him and so I would
never just be like otherwise I would
have done something of his just you know
to do it but I know that wasn't his
thing